hey Disney's back and who doesn't love
that tangled now it's no secret I love
the good old-fashioned Disney
Animation's so when Disney comes out
with a movie that looks like it's taken
it back to princesses and castles and
pretty much everything I know them for
I'm instantly interested so tangled is
pretty much Disney's take on the story
of Rapunzel who's pretty much the cutest
and hottest princess since Jasmine come
on can you deny that she's pretty much
that friend you had you know that friend
that had the really paranoid parent that
didn't let the kid go outside and play
in the mud and sand and build sand
castles and whatnot her and she gets
paired up with Flynn different Flynn
that Flynn a really narcissistic yet
awesome thief adventure who's pretty
much seen it all so then they go on
their adventure together for mutual gain
I'm gonna be perfectly honest I really
enjoyed tangled most of that was because
of Flynn
oh yeah sure tangled features a
strongest sort of cunning female lead
you know as a woman to serve to be
betrayed nah but I mean come on back to
the cool dude
he was like Nathan Drake from Uncharted
in the Renaissance era imagine if
Aladdin was played by Nathan Fillion
there you go
and the contrast between the two
characters like really worked well
together in that whole Union Yang kind
of way I liked it now in order for it to
be a true Disney movie a classic it has
to be a musical yeah people need to
break out in song and dance at random
yet monumental moments in the movie I
don't make the rules
and was there music there was but maybe
it's because I grew up with the songs in
the Disney movies of the 90s but I don't
see the songs entangled becoming as
iconic as like the circle of life or
never had a friend like me actually
thought there is one song that I really
liked I thought it was funny but you
know go figure it's the funny song that
I like and as for the characters I like
the characters even though two of them
were animals not those two although when
the cameras are off but you just don't
know there was a horse and a chameleon
in the movie both of which felt like
characters neither of which talked but I
like them both more so the horse and the
chameleon so if you would like classic
Disney movies with a modern twist with
the main characters you will like
tangled I promise so check it out
because tangled is Disney tacular
in that modern twist kind of way but not
too modern because it still takes place
in the medieval times I think that is an
official rating pact I'm pretty sure
it's a rating the only tangles can get
and if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more than click
right here to see more